what I would like to discuss today with
you gentlemen is your anime origin story
if you will how did you get into anime
and how you know you discovered that you
were going to go down this rabbit hole
of never coming this beautiful medium
that we all we all love and hate yeah I
mean you wanna go first Joey because I
feel like you have the most yuck most
likely yeah probably I probably awful
yeah actually yeah okay I'm having to
follow up his story is gonna be fun but
whatever I mean yeah I guess like mine
is unique in the sense that like and
would you say I'm the only Ana tuber
that has like grown up with anime like
and when I said growing up I mean like
from like age of like conceptual thought
age of conceptual thoughts I think just
being raised in a household to the
Japanese Peron yeah probably has an
immediately different attitude towards
anime then that we would experience in
like Western right because like you know
when most people say like oh I grew up
with like you know that usually start to
like age late you know yeah so like
basically like I grew up like watching
Pokemon and like what else can remember
watching uh I guess like before that the
like before Pokemon or anything like
that or you know before I started
watching like one piece of like
Dragonball like you're the Sean in jump
stuff like Japanese kids grow up with
this like very certain array of like
kids anime yeah which is just absolutely
not known overseas Doraemon Doraemon was
probably like the most well known but
like you don't like see a Nana to bow a
five thousand reviewed Doraemon let's go
one series that I grew up watching like
alongside thorium or was this show
called saws a song yeah just like the
longest-running zoo just running and
yeah and nobody outside of Japan has
heard of it I didn't know about it until
you I was having perspective in my mom
died right so it's been going on since
like the sixties and I think there's
like five thousand is it going
how like I don't know please because
like it's really weird because the
concept of that show is like it's just a
revolving around this family living in
Japan and it's just like the most like
normal ask slice of life showed that
I've ever seen but I also think to
myself like how can you come up with
like 40 years worth of topics and not be
like oh maybe we did cover this topic
like 25 years ago in one of those
episodes there must be absolute that
overlap like I feel you can't make that
many episodes and not overlap I know I
probably could overlap but no-one's
rewatching that show right it's other
things if it's on TV watching right
it's like uh-uh they covered this topic
in episode 1700 know there's one super
fan on a path as you see in every
episode and just knows everything about
every episode that seems to be
and Doraemon seem to be the one thing
where if you ask anyone in Japan
do you watch anime they'll be like oh
yeah thought I'm on I'm like oh I'm in
like you know the other boobs in that
please don't
but like but like watching The Rime on
and like sauce Ison and like I could
list off a number know but late there's
just like a certain number of shows that
I think like it's just become tradition
now no matter what generation or like if
you're born born and raised in the city
or the you know the middle of nowhere
every kid grows up watching these like
really specific set of shows you know
and that's just like normal to them you
know that's like watching you know a
Peppa Pig yeah it's like it's just like
you don't even think about like oh yes
it's a cartoon yeah it's just something
to show to you yeah right
and then yeah like I guess like the
concept of like anime anime didn't hit
me until maybe like always thought when
I started watching like one piece like
Dragon Ball and like probably around
like the Pokemon time so I reckon when I
was like five or six years a white girl
so so when you start realizing what
anime isn't probably getting into it
that's when probably we started to watch
our first anime which was Pokemon right
but like in my head I'm like you
Pokemon is an anime and like Samurai
Jack as a cartoon yeah because at that
time like around like 500 CC's old
that's when I started like watching like
Cartoon Network right and I'd like to
think that we grow up and like the
Golden Age of college network I mean I'd
say so
we had Samurai Jack that's right Jack
like Dexter's Lab cow and chicken yeah
and an ad like so many amazing shows and
to me that's like okay things on Cartoon
Network are cartoons yeah but things
that are on like the VHS tapes that my
grandma would same to me oh these
animals anime yeah so for me there's
like a really clear distinction so like
I didn't have like one day this sudden
realization they're like oh [ __ ]
doraemon is an anime yeah because it was
just so natural to me